In the Summer of 2007, in the heart of a forest
in Northern California, hundreds of people
were gathered for a yearly art and music festival.
It was meant to be a celebration, a weekend
filled with creative expression, dancing,
and, sure, probably some illegal substances.
But it was all set to be a mostly wholesome
affair and one that the attendees had been
looking forward to all year.
On the evening of the festival’s first night,
after a day of painting, performance art,
interpretive dance, and folk-pop fusion, the
organizers put together a massive bonfire.
Everyone gathered around, roasting marshmallows
and vegan hot dogs, and breaking out their
acoustic guitars for a sing-along.
It was all going well, and they were heading
into the third refrain of Kumbaya, when a
group of friends adding logs to the fire noticed
something odd.
Some of the flames at the edge of the fire
pit were moving in a different direction than
the rest.
While most of the flames flickered upward,
some tilting slightly with the direction of
the wind, these flames were moving sideways
against the wind, stretching themselves out
toward the grass.
It seemed bizarre, impossible, and they wondered
at first if perhaps the brownies they had
eaten earlier had more than just chocolate
in them.
But then, the flames kept moving, taking on
a familiar shape.
They were dancing orange and yellow flames,
there was no doubt about that, but they also
seemed almost like…fingers.
The fingers extended outward, grasping for
something.
Attached to the fingers was a hand, then an
arm.
Another hand joined it, fingers twisting into
the grass, which dried and crackled at its
touch.
One of the friends, a young woman named Flower,
attempted to alert one of the event staff,
but they were too busy trying to get their
marshmallow to the perfect shade of golden
brown.
Unable to get any help, she watched helplessly
as the fiery hands dragged a head, a torso,
and the rest of a humanoid body behind them.
It looked like the shape of an ordinary man,
with the glaring exception that it was made
entirely out of fire.
It stepped out of the fire pit, and began
to take slow, halting strides toward the gathered
crowd.
Now, everyone took notice of what was happening.
First, they froze in shock, staring at this
being of pure flame, unbearable heat radiating
off of him as he moved closer and closer.
When he reached out a hand toward Flower,
and the arm of Flower’s dress ignited in
flames on contact, the first scream broke
through the silence.
When they marketed this year’s event as
“Burning Man in the woods” this was not
what they had in mind.
But there he was, just the same, a man made
of flames tearing through what was meant to
be a peaceful and happy event with no dangers
beyond exhaustion, dehydration, and maybe
a noise complaint or two.
Instead, the crowd scattered in every possible
direction, running for their lives.
It was already late for poor Flower, who fell
to the ground shrieking in agony as the fire
engulfed the organic material of her dress,
and the flaming man pulled her into its deadly
arms.
Her screams went quiet, drowned out by the
crackling roar of the fire as it fed on her
flammable body.
Once Flower was nothing but a pile of bones
and ashes, the entity began to walk slowly,
purposefully, through the woods with its arms
outstretched.
It brushed its fingertips over everything
it passed, every tree, every stump, every
plant or scrap of fabric torn off on a branch.
The fire began to spread like, well, wildfire.
By the time the first festival-goers made
it out of the forest and into the nearest
town to get help, dozens of acres of forest
were ablaze and over 50 people were dead.
The fire department was deployed to the forest,
where they were able to contain the blaze
after hours of work.
Meanwhile, word of the man made of fire that
destroyed the art and music festival reached
the only people qualified to deal with such
a creature: The SCP Foundation.
They deployed operatives embedded in the local
police force, who joined the fire department
under the guise of providing reinforcements.
Once the blaze was contained and the area
was largely safe to enter, they followed the
path of the fire and tracked the being responsible
for all of the destruction.
They found it, shrunk to the size of a small
child, huddled in the fire pit where it all
began as if it was hiding from the fire hoses.
Then, they apprehended the being later designated
SCP-457.
SCP-457 is comprised of unknown materials,
though obviously it is made up of something
flammable.
Whatever it is, it is made up of something
invisible and impossible to detect by any
known scientific means.
The only visible aspect of the entity is the
flames it produces, which tend to make up
a humanoid shape as long as it has enough
fuel to reach that size.
If it does not have enough fuel, it shrinks
in size, becoming as small as the single flame
atop a lit match.
In its smallest form, it is indistinguishable
from any other small flame, except for the
occasional display of independence such as
jumping to other fires or flammable materials,
which it can then use to grow larger.
When it is large enough to take on a human
form, SCP-457 displays human-like intelligence
and is capable of communicating through writing
- which it does by burning letters into surfaces
with its flames - or even through speech.
Though it lacks the anatomy to produce a traditional
voice, it produces coherent sounds via pressurized,
superheated air as well as the crackle of
its flames.
If provided with enough fuel to grow beyond
humanoid size, the entity can split into two
or more beings, depending on how much fuel
it is given.
However, this split state does not last, as
the separate instances of SCP-457 will attempt
to attack each other until they are the only
one left standing.
SCP-457 seems to want nothing more than to
consume more and more fuel and spread as far
as it can.
It has shown a troubling ability to learn
and adapt, purposefully breaking and interfering
with sprinkler systems in the building and
setting up elaborate traps for personnel it
does not like.
Dr. Smythe, head of the research team assigned
to SCP-457, conducted an interview with the
subject on a rare day when it was feeling
cooperative, in order to better assess its
psychology and motivations.
Dr. Smythe entered SCP-457’s containment
chamber, carrying a fire extinguisher in case
of any hostility on the part of the entity.
He stood on the other side of the blast shielded
window, for extra protection.
It crackled pleasantly in the corner, seeming
to welcome him inside.
He asked if it was capable of, or willing
to speak.
It answered yes.
He asked it how it felt about being confined.
It responded plainly: “Dislike.
No fuel.
No Air.”
When Dr. Smythe reminded the entity that it
had enough air and fuel to survive, it argued
that it could not burn, and had no fuel.
To clarify, Dr. Smythe asked, “Are you saying
that you cannot grow?”
At this question, SCP-457 moved back and forth
through a small section of the room, as if
pacing and looking for something.
It said, “Grow.
Need.
Must grow,” and when asked how it felt,
it simply said: “Hungry.”
As the questioning continued, the entity approached
the window and stretched a hand made of flame
toward the glass.
For a moment, it stopped responding to Dr.
Smythe.
In order to get the being’s attention back,
he casually brought up the subject of water.
At the very mention of it, SCP-457 let out
a high-pitched scream and pressed itself against
the window in a threatening gesture.
Dr. Smythe warned that it must move away from
the window, or it would be doused in water.
It moved back, but screamed and hissed for
several more minutes, offended and upset.
SCP-457 resumed its pacing, at a more aggressive
speed and intensity.
All the while, it repeated: “Want fuel.
Want air.
Want burn.
Want to burn.
Want to burn.”
Again and again, getting louder and louder
as it moved.
Dr. Smythe was perplexed by this behavior,
noting that there was no way out and wondering
what it could be trying to accomplish.
At this point, the interview took a turn for
the disastrous.
Somehow, SCP-457 was able to damage the sprinkler
system and a section of the fuel injector
that had been providing it with a small stream
of fuel.
With the nozzle broken open, several gallons
of gasoline came flooding out, allowing the
entity to grow to an incredible size in a
sudden, massively destructive blast.
Exploiting a weakness in the blast shielding,
SCP-457 was able to escape its containment
for several minutes, burning its way down
the hall of the facility until the larger
sprinkler system activated, sending it hissing
back to its cell.
There, it was apprehended by a team of guards
and herded into a new, higher-security cell.
It is unknown how exactly the entity became
aware of the weaknesses in its containment
chamber, but this incident revealed that it
is a highly intelligent being capable of problem-solving.
However it learned this information, and figured
out how to exploit it, the Foundation realized
that more extensive measures would have to
be taken to keep it locked down and keep the
general population safe.
Due to the dangerous nature of SCP-457’s
corporeal form, highly specialized containment
procedures have been put in place to keep
the flame from spreading.
The entity is kept in a 5 by 5-meter chamber
with at least nine inches of fireproofing
in place, including asbestos and perlite.
The observation window is blast-proof and
resistant to extremely high temperatures.
The room’s opening is made up of temperature-controlled
and airtight chambers that can be sealed in
the event of an escape attempt.
The room itself is kept at a high humidity
level and has a drain installed on the floor,
with a sprinkler system in the ceiling and
emergency hoses that can be operated if additional
water is needed.
A small portion of the room is free from water,
but only enough so that SCP-457 can maintain
its shape and protect itself from moisture.
Any personnel that enter SCP-457’s containment
unit must wear Class-A temperature-controlled
and flame-resistant suits, and must enter
in groups of three.
Two of the three members of each group must
be armed with blast shields and fire extinguishers.
Personnel are not permitted to enter the containment
chamber for any reason other than providing
daily fuel or fixing any issues with the room
or its sprinkler system.
In some ways, its containment procedures are
reminiscent of a particularly spicy variant
of SCP-173.
If the entity attempts to attack any personnel,
it can be deterred via the application of
fire extinguishers or hoses until it backs
down.
If it escapes from containment, further sprinkler
systems will be activated throughout the facility
in order to contain the fire.
The highest priority, aside from keeping the
entity contained, is keeping it fed.
Because it needs constant fuel in order to
survive, the Foundation is currently prioritizing
finding an infinitely renewable source of
fuel.
Though many have been proposed, including
the use of other SCPs such as SCP-2689 and
SCP-124, no source has been officially approved
yet.
In the meantime, they keep the burning being
fed and happy, or as happy as it can be.
It will never be truly satisfied until a day
arrives when it can be permitted to spread
as far and wide as it wishes, to burn and
feed and engulf everything in sight.
Let’s all hope that day never comes, but
if you start to feel unusually hot, if the
walls seem to suddenly blacken around you,
and you hear the final crackles before the
hissing tongues of flame lick at your bubbling
skin...Well, by that point, it’ll already
be too late.
Now go check out “THIS SCP DOES NOT EXIST
- SCP-3930 - The Pattern Screamer” and “SCP-173
Origin Story - How 173 Got to Site-19” for
more strange and usual SCP’s!